إليكم
النتيجة الأكثر إثارة للاهتمام
للقمة التي استمرت ثلاثة أيام بين فلاديمير بوتين وشي جين
بينغ والتي حظيت باهتمام إعلامي محدود
واصفة محادثاتهما. قال بوتين إننا
نؤيد استخدام اليوان الصيني في
التسويات بين روسيا
ودول آسيا وإفريقيا وأمريكا اللاتينية.
لذا فإن
ثاني أكبر اقتصاد في العالم وأكبر
مصدر للطاقة يحاولان معًا
جاهدين إضعاف
هيمنة الدولار كمرساة
للنظام المالي الدولي. هل سينجحان؟
الدولار هو
آخر قوة عظمى باقية في أمريكا، فهو
يمنح واشنطن قوة اقتصادية وسياسية لا مثيل لها،
ويمكنها فرض العقوبات.
على البلدان من جانب واحد، مما يحرر
ذلك البلد من أجزاء كبيرة من
الاقتصاد العالمي، ويمكن لواشنطن أن تنفق
بحرية على يقين من أن
بقية العالم سيشتري ديونها، وقد خلقت
الحرب ضد أوكرانيا، جنبًا إلى جنب مع
نهج المواجهة المتزايد الذي تنتهجه واشنطن تجاه الصين، اقتصادًا
مثاليًا.  العاصفة التي تعمل فيها كل من
روسيا والصين على تسريع
جهود التنويع بعيدًا عن
الدولار،
تحتفظ البنوك المركزية بقدر أقل من
احتياطياتها بالدولار وتتم تسوية معظم التجارة
بينهما
باليوان، وتبذل أيضًا جهودًا لجعل
الدول الأخرى تحذو حذوها.  لقد
تعاملت إدارة بايدن مع
الحرب الاقتصادية ضد روسيا بشكل
فعال للغاية من خلال بناء تحالف يضم
جميع الاقتصادات المتقدمة في العالم تقريبًا،
مما يجعل من الصعب الهروب
من الدولار إلى عملات أخرى مستقرة ذات قيمة عالية
مثل اليورو أو
الجنيه الاسترليني أو الدولار الكندي لأن
تلك  الدول تتحارب أيضًا مع
روسيا.
ما كان يمكن أن يكون نقطة تحول أكثر حدة لدور
الدولار هو
قرار دونالد ترامب في مايو 2018 بالانسحاب
من الاتفاق النووي الإيراني،
وقد عارض الاتحاد الأوروبي بشدة هذه
الخطوة لكنه شاهد كما
تعني هيمنة الدولار.  أن إيران تم
استبعادها على الفور من الاقتصاد العالمي،
اقترح جان كلود يونكر، رئيس المفوضية الأوروبية آنذاك،
تعزيز دور اليورو
دوليًا لحماية القارة
مما أسماه الأحادية الأنانية،
وحددت المفوضية طريقًا
لتحقيق ذلك، ولم يحدث ذلك.
هناك الكثير من الشكوك الجوهرية حول
مستقبل اليورو نفسه،
وهيمنة الدولار راسخة بقوة لأسباب عديدة
وجيهة، فالاقتصاد المعولم يحتاج إلى
عملة واحدة لسهولة
وكفاءة الدولار مستقر، ويمكنك
شراؤه وبيعه في أي وقت،
ويحكمه السوق إلى حد كبير.  ليست
أهواء الحكومة، ولهذا السبب فإن
جهود الصين لتوسيع
دور اليوان على المستوى الدولي لم تنجح بشكل
مثير للسخرية، فإذا أراد شي جين بينغ التسبب في
أكبر قدر من الألم لأمريكا، فإنه
سيحرر قطاعه المالي ويجعل
اليوان منافسًا حقيقيًا للدولار،
لكن ذلك من شأنه أن  خذه في اتجاه
الأسواق والانفتاح الذي هو
عكس أهدافه المحلية الحالية،
كل ما قيل إن استخدام واشنطن
للدولار كسلاح خلال العقد الماضي
دفع العديد من الدول المهمة إلى البحث
عن طرق للتأكد من أنها لن
تصبح روسيا التالية.
تكشف الأرقام أن حصة
الدولار في احتياطيات البنك المركزي العالمي
قد انخفضت من حوالي 70 قبل 20 عامًا
إلى أقل من 60 بالمائة اليوم،
وتتراجع بشكل مطرد.
ويحاول الأوروبيون والصينيون
بناء أنظمة دفع دولية
خارج "سويفت" السعودية التي يهيمن عليها الدولار.
تغازلت فكرة
تسعير نفطها باليوان،
وتقوم الهند بتسوية معظم
مشترياتها النفطية من روسيا بعملات غير الدولار،
وقد تكون العملات الرقمية
بديلاً آخر وفي الواقع
أنشأ البنك المركزي الصيني أحد هذه البدائل، كل هذه
البدائل تضيف تكاليف ولكن الأخير  كان
ينبغي أن تعلمنا بضع سنوات أن
الدول على نحو متزايد على استعداد لدفع
الثمن عندما تريد أهدافًا سياسية لأهداف
ترامب الاقتصادية،
ونحن نستمر في البحث عن
بديل واحد للدولار
ولن يكون هناك بديل
ولكن هل يمكن أن تعاني العملة من الضعف
بآلاف التخفيضات  يبدو أن هذا هو
السيناريو الأكثر ترجيحًا الذي
يشير إليه المؤلف والمستثمر ريتشارد شارما الآن ولأول مرة
في ذاكرتي، لدينا
أزمة مالية دولية كان فيها الدولار
يضعف بدلاً من أن يرتفع،
وأتساءل عما إذا كانت هذه علامة على أشياء
قادمة  إذا كان الأمر كذلك على الأمريكيين أن يقلقوا، فقد
تحدثت الأسبوع الماضي عن
العادات الجيوسياسية السيئة التي طورتها واشنطن
بسبب
وضعها الأحادي القطب الذي لا مثيل له،
فهذا صحيح أكثر من الناحية الاقتصادية، فقد
اعتاد السياسيون الأمريكيون
على الإنفاق دون أي
قلق على ما يبدو بشأن العجز، وقد ارتفع الدين العام في
أمريكا تقريبًا  خمسة أضعاف من
حوالي ستة ونصف تريليون دولار
قبل 20 عامًا إلى واحد وثلاثين ونصف
تريليون دولار اليوم، وقد نجح
بنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي في حل سلسلة من
الأزمات المالية من خلال توسيع ميزانيته العمومية بشكل كبير بما
يقرب من 12 ضعفًا من حوالي
730 مليار دولار قبل 20 عامًا.  إلى
حوالي 8.7 تريليون دولار اليوم،
كل هذا لا ينجح إلا بسبب
الوضع الفريد للدولار،
فإذا فاز ذلك فإن أمريكا ستواجه
حسابًا لم يسبق له مثيل.